i wonder
from almost an ai perspective but just
computationally
is the brain just mostly a prediction
machine then
like is the perception just the
nice little feature added on top like
the
both the the integration of new
perceptual information
i wonder how big of an impressive system
is that relative to just the big
predictor model construction well i
think that we can we can look to
evolution for that for
at one answer which is that when you go
back
you know 550 million years give or take
we you know the world was populated by
creatures really ruled by creatures
without brains
um and um you know that's a biological
statement
not a political statement really world
with people calling dinosaurs dumb
you're talking about like oh no i'm not
talking about dinosaurs honey i'm
talking
way back further back than that um
really these they're these little
little um creatures called uh amphioxus
which is the modern
it's a or a lancet that's the modern
animal
but it's an animal that scientists
believe is very similar
to um our common the common ancestor
that we share
uh with invertebrates um because uh
basically because of the tracing back
the molecular
genetics and cells and that animal
had no brain it had some cells that
would later
turn into a brain but in that animal
there's no brain but that animal also
had no head
and it had no eyes and it had no ears
and it had really
really no senses for the most part it
had
very very limited sense of touch it had
an eye spot for um not for seeing but
just for
um in training to circadian rhythm to
light and dark
um and it had no hearing it had a
vestibular cell
so that it could keep upright in the
water
at the time approx we're talking
evolutionary scale here so
you know give or take some 100 million
years or something
but at the time you know what are the
vertebrate like whenever when a backbone
evolved and a brain evolved a full
brain that was when a head evolved with
sense
with sense organs and when um
that's when your viscera like internal
systems involved so
the answer i would say is that um that
senses
nurse motor neuroscientists people who
study the control of motor
behavior believe that
senses evolved in the service of motor
action
so the idea is that like what
triggered the what triggered what was
what was the big evolutionary change
what was the big pressure
uh that made it useful to have
eyes and ears and a visual system and an
auditory system and a brain basically
and you know and the answer that um
is you know commonly entertained right
now is that it was predation
that when at some point an
animal evolved that deliberately ate
another animal
and this launched an arms race between
predators and prey
and it became very useful to have senses
right so these these little antioxidants
these little amphioxy
you know don't really have they
they don't have an they're not aware of
their environment very much really
they um uh
and so being able to
look up ahead and you know
ask yourself you know is that you know
should i eat that or will it eat me
um is is a very useful thing so the idea
um is that senses sense sense data
is not there for consciousness it didn't
evolve for the purposes of consciousness
it didn't evolve
for the purposes of experiencing
anything um
it evolved uh in the cert to be in the
service of motor control
however maybe it's useful
um this is why you know scientists
sometimes
uh avoid questions about why things
evolved that this is
what philosophers call this teleology
you might be able to say something about
how uh things evolve
but not necessarily why we don't really
know the why
uh that's all speculation but the y is
kind of nice here this
the interesting thing is uh that was the
first
element of social interaction is am i
gonna eat you or are you gonna eat me
and for that
it's useful to be able to see each other
sense each other
uh that's kind of fascinating that there
was a time when life didn't eat each
other
or they did by accident right so an
amphioxus for example
well um it kind of like gyrates in the
water and then it plants itself
in the sand like a blade of like a
living blade of grass and then it just
filters
whatever comes into its mouth right so
it is it is eating but it's not
actively hunting and when
um the concentration of food
decreases it the amphioxus can
sense this and so it basically
wriggles itself randomly to some other
spot which
probabilistically will have more food
than wherever it is
so it's not really you know it's not
guiding its actions
um on the basis of it's not we would say
there's no real intentional action
in that in that in the traditional sense
you